what what happened the last two years
you know
we were watching some things that you
can't go to work you have to stay at
house you can't even get out if you do
get out people
half the stuff didn't even make any
sense like i was saying earlier it was
like we're watching a movie a horror
movie
you know like what was that one movie
where you can only get out a certain
time and people can go out and kill is
it purge what's that one movie where
it's purge right yeah it so what
happened what got to this point is that
how
australia would have typically chosen to
handle a crisis like covet a pandemic
like covet or did politics heavily get
involved in the last couple years it's a
really good question i've done a lot of
thinking about it jordan peterson asked
me on his show the same question and
i sort of reverted to form a little bit
i suppose and sort of thought the
training when we're in politics is be
careful what you say about your own
country outside it and it wasn't quite
tough enough the reality in australia
was as i mentioned as a federation
what you saw internationally more than
anything else was the city of melbourne
in the state of victoria which is led by
a pretty far left socialist premier
um yeah it was bad and it's still going
on because they arrested and handcuffed
a pregnant lady
for you know doing the wrong thing
in a way that doesn't pass what we would
call the pub test do you have that
expression
uh it means that if you were down at the
pub and you said uh this is what the
government's done to a citizen people
would say that is unacceptable the pub
test yeah like pop test got it like
you're hanging out at the bar drinking
shooting with your buddies and you're
like hey what are your thoughts on this
and everyone's like yeah i don't know
about that mate but here's what troubles
me i'm going to say it even though i'm
in another country i don't know what's
happened to some of the
you know australians were known for
having a bit of a larikan spirit for
being resilient for being tough and they
you know my father was involved in the
second world war the north african
desert the first battle of any
significance where the when the nazis
took a back footstep
it was there
general rommel against the english
general montgomery my father was
fighting with the australians why do i
mention because rommel wrote in his book
that these
soldiers from australia
are the finest product of the british
empire there are another owners like
them they were tough they had initiative
they had resilience they would fight for
freedom
but they expected freedom in return
and i don't quite know what happened i'm
going to say that to you in the
australian psych particularly in
melbourne that's made them give way
to an expertocracy that says we know
what's best for you
and they look like rewarding that father
by re-electing him partly because the
opposition's not strong enough so i
can't give you a full answer but i can
confirm to you it is concerning
the biggest state in australia is new
south wales
where a lot of this idiocy
wasn't as bad
but what it was about uh you know
melbourne uh equal biggest city and
that's a true international city that
people were prepared it was the most
locked down city in the world and we now
know that the economic and the cultural
and social costs were worse than the
disease i don't think you could really
argue that point so there was a
difference between what was going on in
new south wales that's where sydney is
right i was that was there 10 years ago
versus melbourne which is just south of
that right when queensland is just above
that yep perth on the left side most of
the most of the citizenry is on the
right side of the country but there was
a clear difference between what was
going on in melbourne and sydney so
melbourne was the
the centerpiece of the lockdown state is
what you're saying it was the lockdown
capital of the world wow so you would
say a melbourne is like more like a
california or a new york for us
yeah okay or maybe even worse than that
way worse well the lockdown capital of
the world
um it is worrying but don't miss this
thing that i'm saying what's happening
because i think it's happening in a lot
of western countries
a lot of citizens see the great american
model was let's get this clear it's
about the individual so the individual
that's your core belief
the supremacy of the individual
and their beliefs should shape the
culture and values
which were downstream of the individual
and government was downstream of the
culture
but we're reversing that we're making
ourselves creatures of the state
and there seems to be something creeping
in the what might be called the
progressive left the post-modernist and
neo sort of a cult marx or sort of world
where people want
bureaucracies and experts and
expertocracies if i can use that word
that's mangling the english language
isn't it
i don't think you probably never mangle
the english language in america but
there seems to be this desire for others
to tell us what to do why the why is
that creating such momentum though like
you know i think it's fear i think you
know your american founders got this
right they
you know
if
you've got to defend freedom if you're
not really careful the people will go
will give up their freedoms
for safety
so you've got to explain what real
safety is you've got to explain what
freedom is and we're washing it out of
our culture so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]